I don't think so hopefully they were
expecting these these results but I
think what it does it allows us to go
into the the merger with a strong set of
numbers rather than the the other the
other possibility of going in with a
really weak set of numbers so now it's
great to it's great to have such a
strong set and great profitability
dividend are poor dividend well covered
all of these sort of all of these sort
of things and have clients reacted to
the merger yeah I think well I mean I
think clients understand that size does
matter in asset management and that that
having a global business requires you to
be a certain size so so certainly they
understand that the rise and rise of
passive in the u.s. is hitting the big
US fund managers so gain clients clients
see that and I think it's about scale as
well
ie can we do everything for a client and
and certainly the merger with Standard
Life gives us a better solutions
offering them we had all of these sort
of things so so now all I think the
client reaction has been better than I
hoped it would be
Tonya's reported at the weekend that
you're making retention payments to keep
some of your staff and managers onboard
which could be as much as 35 million
pounds is there a danger that this
merger is going to prove to be better
for employees than for customers no I
don't think so I mean I look it's it's
the context of this as an 11 billion
pound deal so any sort of retention pool
will be less than half a percent of the
the total deal value but I think the key
thing here is the clients want us to put
a scheme in place to retain the fund
managers that are managing their money
so I think it's it's very much done for
the benefit of the client rather than
anyone else because as I stress they
want to see stability with the people
that manage their portfolios it would
Aberdeen or Standard Life fund managers
vote in favor of a merger where a
company was doing the
sort of thing in other sectors yeah I
think so I mean I think if it's a people
business I think you have to recognize
that the the talent as we always say
goes up and down in the lift every day
so I think I think yeah no I think I
think we would very much do that we
probably did when the Hendersons
Janice deal but I think any business
where where the goodwill is such a large
extent of the transaction you really do
need to retain that pool of talent and
looking at the investment world more
widely at the moment people are
obviously obsessing a lot of that big
geopolitical factors is everyone taking
their eye off the ball in terms of
company earnings too much
I think company earnings have been fine
I mean we're seeing a good recovery
especially in emerging markets but but
yeah I it's a very good point because
people people ignore the geopolitical
they talk about all the geopolitical
points and and economics I think what
we've always tried to do in Aberdeen is
do as you say which is focus on the
company's financials would far rather
discuss politics and geopolitical events
rather than sit doing the work of
analyzing individual companies and
that's what we've tried to do take the
noise away and really concentrate on
whether this company is a good
investment or not